women in Saudi Arabia are set to drive
legally for the first time this weekend
the government there lifted the world's
last ban on female drivers earlier this
month they can take the wheel starting
on Sunday many gives Saudi Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman credit for the
change Holly Williams is in the capital
Riyadh with some of the obstacles Saudi
women still face Holly good morning good
morning women here in Saudi Arabia have
been waiting and protesting for the
right to drive for nearly 30 years but
now just as they're set to get behind
the wheel the Saudi government has begun
arresting some women who've dared to
campaign for their rights on Sunday for
the first time Salma Youssef will
finally be able to drive herself to work
and her three children to school it's
will changed my life it will change my
family it's freedom yeah it's freedom
yeah she passed her test last week and
chauffeured us around the campus of this
women's university where they've built
her females only driving school that's
perfect in this conservative Islamic
country where women still need a male
relatives permission to travel overseas
or get married brave Saudi women fought
for the right to drive illegally taking
the wheel and shaming their government
Saudi comedians satirized the sexist
attitudes behind the driving ban
[Music]
and poked fun at religious conservatives
who said driving could damage a woman's
ovaries but now as the Saudi government
finally allows women to hit the roads
it's also begun arresting women's rights
campaigners who've demanded total
equality reportedly including Madera
al a Jewish who we interviewed in 2014
the car for the Saudi women have become
the symbol of wanting our voices to be
heard and our needs to be heard we
understand Madea Allah drew has now been
released but other women remain behind
bars
Gayle all right Thank You Holly this may
be the first of many changes there we'll
see ya I'm so glad they're getting in
the car
enjoy Thank You Holly Williams reporting
from Saudi Arabia